do you think bitcoin or some other
cryptocurrency will become the reserve
currency of the world at some point
so this is kind of a controversial idea
but i actually think yes um
i do think bitcoin could end up becoming
a reserve currency of the world there's
so you know i've been reading ray dalio
recently um
with his new book like the changing
world order and i i thought it was a
really well researched book um
he talks in there he looks back at
history right he looks at like empires
and
um you know going back to various
chinese empires the dutch and ottomans
and everybody and
how did they rise and they they were
able to have the reserve currency as
they as they rose and what produced that
like it came from you know good
education and innovation and better
trade and anyway
so
the us by some measures is kind of looks
like it's maybe it's had a really good
run and it's coming down a little bit
and china is kind of kind of coming up
who knows how that will play out by the
way like the world is very complicated
it could that could switch
um
but i guess
if the u.s dollar is going to be seeing
more inflation in the future
the chinese yuan is not like
necessarily better right i mean
they have a ton of debt as well and um
you know it's not like
you could really that that the yuan
could be inflated as well right i
probably will be and so i do think that
there's this group of people today which
probably most traditional um
i don't know like the people uh
who run big banks and like governments
and stuff that they're not this is not
really on their radar today but i think
there's there's a basically a group of
younger people in that kind of
you know 25 35 year old range who are
tech savvy
they're starting to think of crypto as
like the primary thing
in their financial life it's like
i basically hold my wealth in crypto and
i use
dollars or euros or whatever if i if i
happen to need something i convert it to
that last minute it's like if i if i go
on if i'm traveling i might convert some
local currency in the moment but that's
not where i hold my most of my wealth
so this segment of the population is not
like
massive yet from a gdp point of view but
um i think it's a leading indicator of
where things could be going and this is
actually good for the world it's kind of
like
especially if china does continue to
rise and it has a more authoritarian
view it'll be kind of this very
centralized east versus a decentralized
west
um where people are in the west in the
free world really kind of embracing
um crypto and a more open fair free
global
financial system which i think will be
enormously beneficial for humanity and i
do think basically bitcoin is the
reserve currency the gold standard of
the crypto economy
um
so that's pretty crazy yeah the gold
standard i mean it's also
like with ray dalio
i feel like china will drive a lot of
this
either in response or directly i mean
i think the ruble i'm not paying as
close attention to the financial systems
but i think they're trying to tie it to
gold
once again so that's an interesting
maybe it'll be one of the more
authoritarian regime that will switch to
bitcoin standard first
and then
um it's the the west that will
out of that pressure will catch up
versus uh versus the other way around
it's
it's it's fascinating to think of what
is the
the forcing function
what kind of perturbation is required to
switch to change anything honestly about
the financial system but
it could be
um as you're saying just waiting for the
people that are young now that are
embracing crypto to
enter the positions of power
essentially
but i hope that's not the case because
that's uh
if for any innovation we have to wait
um sorry to say for the older folk to to
pass away yeah
that's not an efficient way to uh to
make change yeah
that is that's a super interesting topic
of how
people's minds become less plastic as
they age yeah
i guess it's a feature
it's called wisdom but then we also need
the wild ones to explore exploration
versus exploitation
you